on your Channel
so I don't know if we had a clapping
button we would clap right now but we'll
just do that live on air here Pearl so
you started your show February of 2022.
it is now January of 2023. not a
mathematician but that's less than one
year you went from zero to a million
okay what's been your secret how did you
make this happen
YouTube shorts baby yeah yeah I mean
look into the camera right there and
tell all our producers out there who
don't get it what they need to do
um well I just created a system where
all I'd have to do is make content I
wouldn't have to edit I wouldn't have to
do thumbnails I wouldn't have to do
anything I chase down I think the best
people in the business to help run my
channel
um and then we just produce a [ __ ] ton
of content like if we're if my thumbnail
guy is making 30 thumbnails a day and
yours is making two who's going to be
better in three months my thought
process so
um yeah I would just say it was like
frequency and getting a really good team
together
um
you've been doing content for how many
years
10 10 years you've been doing this I'm
not coming at you no you're like
comparing me no no you've been doing
Alex you've been doing content for how
many years about four or five four or
five years
um here's I guess the question that I
want and we'll kind of go down the line
here all of you guys have blown up in
one way or another okay yours has been a
more slow and steady wins the race but
you've got like a Warren Buffett
approach too I love that index investing
out there okay dollar cost averages
friends that beat me in the short term
but in the long term I'm here to stay
until I like you bro anytime you're
going to bring up Warren Buffett in a
question like that you know I know
where's house is from Omaha yeah you
live in Regency in the neighborhood yeah
the Oracle of Omaha absolutely two great
Americans Warren Buffett and Stephen AKA
Destiny Omaha okay so you've been to
slow and steady index investor of
content you've blown the [ __ ] up you've
been at it for four or five years you're
doing your thing you've created a niche
so here's the question that I have today
you have gone let's start with pearl but
each of you you you've gone from making
very little money I assume not having a
lot of money until you're raking in the
dough at this point I know what it is to
get hundreds of thousands of views on
YouTube uh and a million subscribers
you're starting to have money you've
made money with YouTube you're also
starting to make money with YouTube
right like this pays your bills like no
joke
what I want to know is how has your life
changed from going from basically a joke
to broke I'm from broke to no joke kind
of a thing from Zero to Hero how has
life changed
um I actually think my life is pretty
much the same I don't really spend like
much differently I bought some new
clothes okay yeah that's pretty much
that's it yeah I mean the show has more
eyeballs on it but like when I think of
myself a year ago doing the First shows
like I would just say the set's improved
you know better clothes better makeup
but that's pretty much it like I don't
think my life is that different than a
year ago so what are you doing with all
the cash that comes in so I'll give you
an example I'll give you an example
um because you're familiar with the
concept of Lifestyle creep you're
familiar you're gonna [ __ ] use that
expression now I'm gonna like a [ __ ]
copy you know what forget I said that
what were you gonna say again Destiny
[ __ ] forget it dude are you familiar
with lifestyle creep essentially the
lifestyle creep is the more money you
make the more nicer [ __ ] you're gonna
buy right I was only making 80 grand now
I make 150 Grand well obviously I'm
gonna buy a nicer car move it to a nice
apartment buy nicer [ __ ] all right
amazing I'm actually an advocate of
doing the exact opposite I went from
making 20 grand a year to 100 Grand a
year to half a million bucks a year okay
and in that process I didn't creep on
anything I just kind of kept it simple I
didn't get a nicer car I just kind of
and just pocketed the I've been very
clear on this like because aside from
doing Valley team and I work in the
finance space so there's months where
you know you work on commissions and
finance shout out to all the sales
people out there entrees out there you
know what I'm talking about it's feast
or famine some months you might make
five ten Grand some months you might
make 50 or 100 Grand we don't [ __ ]
know but those big months
are the months that separate the winners
from the losers because the losers per
se will go out buy a Rolex go get a
nicer car go out and pop bottles in the
club what I've done kind of like you
what inspired this is I went and bought
a 500 suit and then 99 500 later just
went in the bank
five dollars why don't you ever wear it
what is this
talk coming from the [ __ ] guy damn
that wears pajamas when asked to dress
nice
don't get me started on you please come
on I asked him to dress nice
I told you I liked it I told you I like
to listen you got a t-shirt and a
[ __ ] jacket on what's going on
wearing the same pajamas consistent all
right top to bottom yeah you just owned
being assault I asked Destiny what was
it remember what the text that we
exchanged by the way can you wear it was
like I said no casual or something
in a text like I don't these things
don't exist sweatpants and a d t-shirt
anyway the point that I'm getting at
here is what separates the winners from
a loser sometimes is not spending all
the money that you rightfully made so
you're saying you've only spent it on
suspended I just spend it on the
business so okay the first thing but
that's not spending that's reinvesting
in the business yeah the first I did was
hired people
um so I wanted again I really wanted to
free up my time so and I wanted to
create a system where all I had to do
was sit down and make content I didn't
have to like edit I didn't have to do
any of that and then
um the next thing I bought was the
studio we spent over 100k on our studio
it was like crazy and then the next
thing I'm trying to say for is I want
six months of salaries because my dad
says you have to save up so if you ever
have a bad couple of months you don't
have to like start letting people go so
those are the first three things that I
bought your dad has got some very good
advice for you Destiny since you're
eager to fight with somebody today and
we will allow that there's gonna be a
lot of that but let's just keep it
cordial yeah you had you've been you've
said that some of your family is like
rich as hell you've also my family as a
rich some of my family makes an okay
better money but that lifestyle creep is
real okay
immigrant people yeah okay you you
basically drawn the comparison that like
some of your family is like Wealthy on
the wealthier side however you want to
Define that and some are like on the
poor just regular people's side what's
the biggest uh difference in Lifestyles
and happiness that you've seen between
like the Spenders and we're getting a
lot of [ __ ] consumerism materialism
you always think you can spend your way
into happiness but you absolutely you
cannot you can't do it um a lot of
people try to uh and that lifestyle
creep is real uh especially if you work
in service like late April rolls around
and everybody comes with their tax
returns to like waste it on some dumb
[ __ ] I worked in a casino every time
somebody hits a jackpot they're spending
like half of it at the casino
immediately buying their friend stakes
and everything
um yeah I've always avoided that I drove
here in my nice little 40 000 car I
spend a decent amount I pay 5000 a month
for rent but like other than that I
don't spend money on anything like
coming from being poor to being in this
lifestyle when you're poor it feels like
being poor is like a trap right like
when you're poor or at least for me I
wasn't thinking like God I wish I could
have like a nicer car and a nicer house
I was thinking like God I wish I wasn't
so [ __ ] stressed about bills so now
that I'm wealthy I don't want like a
really nice car in a nice house I just
want like the freedom to like chill like
if I don't want to work for a month or
year like I can do that like I have like
the opportunity to do whatever I want
like I think that's the most important
thing for me okay sorry Nat's asking you
to do what make sure you're speaking to
the money by the way what he said was
very important now go ahead and I was
what do you want to say no just make
sure you speak up for I guess because
you know they want to hear everything
gotcha sorry don't be shy use your voice
look at that smile let's get a close-up
on that by the way let's look at that
smile real quick hello happy Friday make
sure you guys like share subscribe thank
you all for joining and I will be
reading all the super chats today
very nice Alex
what give me give me your career
background like what were you doing
before you got into YouTube and like how
did you know you're working in solar
sales so and I was pretty good at my job
I got promoted several times in the span
of three years I had a traditional
corporate job and then a company I
worked for went bankrupt lost my job had
nine months of unemployment at that
point I had a Facebook group uh so I
kind of ran with it uh in terms of like
what I could do I mean I don't know I
would say I'm like very similar to
Destiny I don't really spend my money on
a bunch of things I just like to have
the freedom I don't have to worry or
stress about bills there's nothing that
I can't really afford you know with the
exception of like boats and [ __ ]
um so yeah so here are you would any of
you guys identify as minimalists
yeah I call myself like a millionaire
minimalist meaning like I don't need a
lot to be happy everyone has the same
big three expenses housing
Transportation food and beverage I spend
a good amount on my housing I spent I
don't have a car I'm at a car in 10
years I'm very like vocal about that and
I don't have a fancy palette unless I'm
taking girl out to dinner it's [ __ ]
Subway with the boys and chicken wings
that's it straight up but here's
something and this is where I want to go
to and open this up for dialogue
our parents baby boomer Generations
there was this Mantra let me know if
you've ever heard this before there was
this Mantra back in the 80s people used
to put it on their bumper stickers on
their cars it was he who dies with the
most toys wins you ever heard that
expression
never no can you pull that up real quick
you had the only parents of that bumper
sticker no my parents didn't like
anybody else he who dies with the most
twins was this was
basically
it came from like the Wall Street movie
greed is good you've ever heard of greed
is good yeah okay we've heard that from
Wall Street uh Michael Douglas Charlie
Sheen everything with no pearl any of
this all right well anyway there was a
there was an article out in the
Washington Post like
a handful of years ago and it was like
breaking news uh he who dies with the
most toys now loses okay it was like
kind of like reaffirming what I
basically believe is that what you
talked about is why you make your money
essentially what Pearl's doing is it's
not to get nicer cars clothes Yachts
boats motorcycles this that the other
anything with the engine USA any that
engine just rent it don't buy it it's so
you can have the keyword what you have
Financial Freedom just being able to
come and go as you please not having to
be at the whim of any job Bill mortgage
you know credit card company just doing
you right so when like when you reinvest
in your business what what do you see
happen like what are the you're planting
a seed so the tree grows for your
business right like what have you seen
because in a year this like we come back
two years from now five years from now
you're gonna see the tree Blossom you're
gonna probably have five million
subscribers at that point like what what
are the early effects that you've seen
from reinvest assessing your business
rather than like going and popping
bottles in the club so to speak well the
first thing I got was time like I used
to do the editing myself the recruiting
myself like it I mean you you know
firsthand it's so much work to do a
couple live shows a week like four a
week so I was doing all the recruiting
all the editing everything so to me when
I reinvested into people it was just
time yeah like that's what I was
expecting when they say time is money
it's a real freaking thing yeah and it
was it was to the point like this summer
I actually I was on a credit card like I
didn't have any money left and because I
knew I'd get paid you know how YouTube
works it's like a month delayed but um
like I paid other people before I even
paid myself because I just wanted time
back because in the first like three
months it was hell oh my God it was hell
and now
that's fun yeah now she's doing it yeah
I love Pearl's demeanor uh Destiny
you're making good money with YouTube
you do good you're I think you're
actually a very necessary voice in this
world especially in the red pill world
because you give a counter argument when
are you gonna drop a couple G's on some
new clothes
the problem is it's a rat race okay
because if I upgrade my threads people
are going to say any new shoes if I get
new shoes people are going to say any
new [ __ ] whatever yeah there's some
people might say that there's like some
people might say that's just a cop-out
and that's an excuse you can go buy a
couple jeans for 30. well hold on you
asked me the reality is I just don't
give a [ __ ] okay I was looking for I
don't care that much what do guys buy
clothes for for girls for money for
dropper I already have all three why the
[ __ ] would I upgrade my [ __ ] clothes
but even your girl trying to impress you
even your girl okay brother even your
girl
is gonna be like baby
the same sweatpants again listen if
Molina wants me to upgrade my [ __ ] I'll
do it for her okay so she doesn't want
you to do that I don't think she carries
what about the little stain you have
right here what what are you talking
about they're black pants I don't have
any stains here okay nice try I'm just
saying you can afford some extra jeans
you can afford some pants how much is a
new razor blade cost what do you got
going on over here house huh yeah
uh this is a beard okay that's a five
o'clock shadow from the next day okay
calm down there buddy all right away
what does he have he's got a beard okay
so you're saying I'm not on your level
this guy knows this guy links me a
website for t-shirts I'm like holy [ __ ]
okay he knows his [ __ ] yeah cuts.com
all right so let's shift Let's help to
advise that we got to know the panel
Destiny ain't [ __ ] spending a dollar
on some new sweatpants he's rocking it
anyway he has a girlfriend by the way if
you like them store.dest destiny.gg buy
your own guys you sell these sweatpants
yeah of course yeah
okay so give her a [ __ ] dog I just
did gotcha yeah all right so here we go
round table here follow me on my Twitter
at uh Destiny the game apparently is
what you link so thanks I you know I
work very much what is it okay oh [ __ ]
okay I'm sorry Destiny did you wake up
on the wrong side of the bed today as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we and we monetized on a
daily
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible